[Music]
an entry ban over omicron
israel closes its borders to foreigners
most israelis have already been
vaccinated twice or even three times
but initial studies suggest the new
virus variant is circumventing some
vaccines
that means even vaccinated individuals
can become infected
omicron is causing a dramatic rise in
infections in south africa
biontech researchers are already
developing a vaccine against the omicron
variant available in march
welcome i'm ben fazoulen south africa
discovered the new variant but that
doesn't mean omicron originated there
it's more a sign of the country's
prowess in gene sequencing we'll talk
about that with virus hunter emma
hodcroft in a moment first this report
stranded travellers
plunging stock markets new lockdowns
call it the omicron effect the variant
was first identified by south african
researchers
lab workers running covet 19 tests
started to find cases that didn't match
known virus profiles so they alerted
virologists who studied the viruses
composition by sequencing its genes
sequencing is a tool that allows
scientists to follow how a virus mutates
that means they analyze genetic material
by reading its components each one like
a letter of the alphabet
south africa has highly advanced
sequencing labs a legacy of the hiv and
tuberculosis epidemics which saw the
country develop significant testing
capabilities now directed towards
coronavirus research
but there's a downside many countries
instituted travel bans on south africa
as soon as omicron was revealed some say
that the country is now being punished
for its transparency and its research
but will such travel bans even work
when you are kind of
taking measure against the country it is
like
it is the measure against a good
surveillance system
so the fact that uh other
cases are being discovered in europe
is not unexpected
and it may happen in other countries
those travel bans are still in place
however even though the virus is known
to have already traveled all over the
world
and now to molecular epidemiologist emma
hodcroft thanks for your time
tell us more about how sequencing
actually works and how you draw
real-life conclusions from mutations
so mutation is really a way of life for
viruses they mutate quite a lot
importantly most of these mutations
won't impact how the virus works but
they're important clues that we
scientists can use because if we see two
viruses that have similar mutations
they're probably more closely related
and when we analyze all of the sequences
of sars cov2 that are available we can
basically make a virus family tree this
lets us trace how the virus has moved
around the world how it's changed over
time and perhaps most importantly how
it's acquired using new mutations that
could indicate the virus is changing how
it works
so how related would you say
omicron and delta are
so one of the things that surprise
scientists about omicron is that it's
actually very distantly related from any
other variant we've seen so far i think
many of us expected that the next
variant would be kind of a child of
delta delta plus something else but
omicron has come a little bit out of
left field we don't actually have many
ancestors for omicron so relatives
nearby that help us understand where it
came from or how it came to be so
different this is something we're hoping
to understand better as we get more data
what does the mutational profile of
omicron tell us about its
transmissibility or or immune
evasiveness
so what really surprised scientists with
omicron is that it has a lot of
mutations in what we call the spike
protein and many people will have heard
of this it's the part of the virus on
the outside that's critical both for the
virus to actually attach to cells and
infect them but also it's the part that
our immune system learns to recognize
when we've been infected or vaccinated
so that if it sees it again it mounts a
good immune response
because omicron has so many mutations
there's real concerns that this could
mean the virus might for example be able
to get into cells faster or it might
have changed so much that our immune
system doesn't recognize it as well and
unfortunately some early data that came
out a few days ago suggests that immune
protection and the protection from
vaccines might be lessened for omicron
this is why scientists are working
really hard to try and better understand
how well protected from omicron we are
and whether it is more transmissible but
we're being told that omicron doesn't
cause such a severe course
of covert 19 in people could it be a
good thing at the end of the day if
if omicron overtakes delta
which
is by most studies more dangerous
so one thing we need to be really
cautious here is that we've only
identified omicron a couple of weeks ago
the data is incredibly early especially
for things like hospitalization if you
get sarah's kobe 2 you don't go to
hospital the next day it might take a
couple of weeks until we know that
you're having a bad outcome so we might
just not be seeing this yet for omicron
but even if omicron does have a slightly
less bad clinical outcome so maybe
slightly fewer people end up going to
hospital what's still really concerning
is that if it transmits really quickly
and it can get around vaccine immunity a
lot of people will get infected at about
the same time so we'll have a huge
number of cases and even a small percent
of a big number is a big number so a lot
if a lot of those people end up needing
hospitalization and care at the same
time that could still overwhelm our
health care systems
what does its genetic code tell us about
its potential origin because you you
mentioned that's there's a big question
mark over that at the moment
so the interesting thing about omicron
as i said is that it doesn't have many
near relatives normally when we identify
a variant we can kind of see it's it's
its grandparents and its great
grandparents and how it might have come
about how it changed over time with
omicron we don't really see this but
scientists have some ideas about why
omicron might be so different for
example it could be that it evolved in
an immunocompromised person when
someone's immune system doesn't work as
well they can't hear the virus quite as
quickly and it can acquire a lot of
mutation
another idea is that it could have been
circulating somewhere just undetected as
you mentioned we don't have good
surveillance everywhere in the world so
it might have grown up somewhere else
and only been picked up when it moved
into south africa
finally there's some speculation that
this could have been a variant that
moved into an animal host and then
jumped back into humans but it's
important to note we haven't seen this
happen in sars kobe 2 where the virus
that came back to humans was actually
worked better in humans in the past it's
generally adapted to the animal of
course that doesn't rule out that that
could be what's happened here and it
could be a combination of two or more of
these things together
and emma can you predict whether or not
omicron is here to stay because only a
few variants have managed to stay around
so this is a really good point we see a
lot of variants emerging with stars kobe
2 some of them become more well known
than others but most of these were
completely wiped out by delta actually
it's still early days so it's hard to
know exactly what impact omicron is
going to have certainly at the moment we
see it growing at quite a fast rate both
in south africa and in countries in
europe that have good surveillance
systems so this implies that it could
overtake delta on the other hand we have
a lot more delta here in europe than
they do in south africa so it might be
that this slows omicron down a little
bit the more data we get over the next
few weeks we'll get a better idea of
what omicron has in store for us
lastly and briefly which genetic signs
would make you suspicious regarding the
evolution of a new variant
so mostly what we look for in new
variants is changes in the spike protein
and things like omicron are exactly what
we've been watching out for where we see
a lot of mutations in areas that our
body needs to recognize the virus and
areas that might impact how fast that
virus can spread from person to person
so this is what we're really looking out
for when we look at new sequences that
are arriving from all around the world
emma holcroft pleasure talking to you
again
and here's a great question to follow up
on that chat with derek williams
boosters tailored to variants we touched
on it earlier
[Music]
is anyone already working on a booster
tailored specifically to the new variant
yes um pretty much all of the companies
that make covet 19 vaccines say
that they have plans in place to respond
to omicron with tweaks to their products
if the new variant proves to be good at
getting around immune defenses
in people who are vaccinated um but we
don't know yet whether
or to what extent
that'll be the case a lot of scientists
do expect that the high number of
mutations in the variant spike protein
will probably translate into it being
better
at shaking off antibodies programmed by
vaccines
to stop earlier versions of the virus
but they're just one factor in the
equation antibodies aren't the only
layer of defense in the immune system
and
other layers might pick up some
potential slack or at least enough to
keep vaccinated people from getting
severely ill
if authorities decide vaccines do need
tweaking then manufacturers of approved
messenger rna vaccines will likely be
the fastest
out of the blocks
both visor and biontec and moderna say
they could be ready to begin producing
doses tailored to omicron
on a massive scale by about march
but don't forget
the bigger problem by far
for now at least continues to be the
delta variant and the vaccines we
already have still work well against it
especially healthcare authorities say
after a booster shot which
raises the number of antibodies in your
body significantly at least for a while
and that increase in quantity
some experts think might help make up
for any potential loss of quality when
it comes to the new variant so
for the time being they say
the right strategy is to continue to
give people boosters of available
vaccines
and wait for more data on omicron
before moving to alter them
[Music]